science is about doing it's not simply
about truth seeking it's a production of
knowledge it's an industry it's about
convincing other scientists it's about
winning funding to do research
everything is governed by specialization
the greater the specialization the
greater the potential blind spot what
often happens in cosmology is
alternative interpretations of the same
phenomena are pretty much ruled out
because they're difficult to explain
theoretically the theoretical framework
is maintained because it's easier to
stick close to the existing model and
amend it ad hoc rather than to think in
Anew it's harder to devise an experiment
for an undeveloped Theory because it
takes a lot of work to develop a theory
it's not just something that's done a
genius man at midnight with a Blackboard
writing some equations and that's it
it's like a lot of hard work a lot of
group work a lot of resources and
funding so this means there's also a
lack of original experiments that are
happening
foreign